Building functions in R is a key
skill that I'll cover in
this section of videos.
In this first video, the basic
structure of a function will
be introduced in the context of
reporting both the mean and
the standard error
of a data set.
I'm going to start by creating
a test data set called d.
Here, d is a sample of 25
observations from a Poisson
distribution of eight
degrees of freedom.
Next, I'd like to ensure that my
test data set is stable, so
if I rerun my code, I'll get
the same kind of results.
I'm going to do this using
the set seed function.
Now if I regenerate my data
multiple times, I get the same
test data set.
Now onto the general structure
of a function.
I'll start by carefully choosing
a function name.
Here I've thought about
this ahead of time.
I'm going to call
it GetMeanAndSE.
Next, I'll assign a function
object to this name using the
function declaration.
I've provided a generic argument
x to represent the
data, and I'll use braces to
contain the code to be
executed using the arguments.
I'll compute the mean, the
length of the data set, and
the standard error of the mean
inside of these braces.
Presently, the function
identifies the mean and the
standard error.
However, the variables m and SE
only exist in the scope of
the function, so when I run the
function I don't actually
get any results.
What I need to do is add
a return statement.
Now when I rerun the function,
the mean and the standard
error will be returned.
This new function
can be helpful.
However, its present output
isn't actually ideal.
It would be nice to make
explicitly clear what each of
the outputs is from
the function.
In the next video, I'll expand
the function to take a look at
this challenge.